since Android 2.0 you've been able to
take advantage of instant run to
dramatically increase your incremental
builds but did you know that Android 2.1
enables dexing process to improve the
time taken for full builds as well as
improving insulin performance dexon
process allows multiple decks processes
to run within a single VM that's also
shared with Gradle a feature that
significantly improves build times
including initial and clean builds that
means you need to increase the maximum
heap size of the Gradle daemon to
incorporate the memory requirements of
the Dex processes open your projects
Gradle properties and modify up from the
default value of one gig to at least two
we're incorporating the memory
requirements of Dex so if you've
increased the Java max heap size in your
module level build or Gradle file from
default of one gig
you'll need to increase the Gradle
daemons vm size accordingly the best
values vary so experiment with the max
heap size and Gradle demand VM values to
see what values work best for you
upgrade to Android studio 2.1 now and
increase the memory allocation of your
Gradle daemon vm to at least two gigs to
enable Dex in process and enjoy much
faster build times for all your Android
projects